Ethics guidance for research involving human
participants has been developed and disseminated
by numerous organizations and agencies at
international, regional, and national levels over
the past 50 years. Adherence to these guidelines
helps to promote the ethical conduct of research
and enhances and protects the rights and wellbeing
of research participants and communities.
A core component of all contemporary
research ethics guidelines
is that research should be subject to prior
ethical review by a competent IRBs or IRB.
Such review is intended to ensure that
the ethical principles and practices put
forward in the guidelines will be
followed in the proposed research.
Standards for the IRB review system
All research with human participants is
presumptively subject to IRB oversight.
IRBs are part of larger research participant
protection programs that also include training
for IRB members and researchers, and
mechanisms to ensure that IRBs work
efficiently and effectively. National governments
have the primary responsibility for ensuring that
IRBs are subject to adequate oversight. Procedures
exist to ensure clear and efficient communication,
harmonization of standards, networking, and
cooperation among national committees and
between different levels of committees, as
applicable. These procedures enable IRBs to
learn about prior decisions by other IRBs that may
be relevant to the proposed research under review.
IRBs may review different types
of research studies, including,
but not limited to, the following:
• clinical trials
• epidemiological research
• social science research
• research on medical records
or other personal information
• research on stored samples
• health systems research
• implementation research
IRBs should be familiar with
the different methodologies
and ethical considerations that apply to
each type of proposed research they review.
Composition of IRB
The IRB is constituted according to a charter
or other document that establishes the manner
in which members and the Chair will be appointed.
The appointing entity ensures that the IRB has a
multidisciplinary and multisectoral membership,
that its composition is gender balanced,
that it reflects the social and cultural
diversity of the communities from which
research participants are most likely to be
drawn, and that it includes individuals with
backgrounds relevant to the areas of research
the committee is most likely to review.
The entity establishing the IRB
takes the following factors into
consideration when appointing members.
1. Members include individuals
with scientific expertise,
including expertise in behavioral or
social sciences; health care providers;
members who have expertise in legal matters
and/or ethics; and lay people whose primary role
is to share their insights about the communities
from which participants are likely to be drawn.
2. Lay people and other members,
whose primary background is not
in health research with human
participants, are appointed in
sufficient numbers to ensure that they
feel comfortable voicing their views.
3. In order to enhance independence, committee
membership includes members who are not affiliated
with organizations that sponsor, fund,
or conduct research reviewed by the IRB.
Committees are large enough to ensure
that multiple perspectives are brought
into the discussion. To this end, quorum
requirements provide that at least five people,
including at least one lay member
and one non-affiliated member,
are present to make decisions
about the proposed research.
IRB resources
The entity establishing the IRB supports it
with adequate resources, including staffing,
facilities, and financial resources to allow the
IRB to effectively carry out its responsibilities.
As an integral part of a health research
institution or health system, an IRB receives:
1. support staff, adequate in number and training
to enable the IRB to carry out its technical
and administrative responsibilities;
2. adequate resources for the staff to
fulfil its assigned functions, including office
space and equipment and supplies (e.g. computers,
stationery, telephones, photocopying machines,
shredding machine) to conduct administrative
business, to store committee files, and
to keep documents secure and confidential;
3. access to appropriate space for the
committee to meet and adequate means for
members to communicate as needed between meetings;
4. adequate financial resources to permit the
committee to produce high-quality work;
5. if considered necessary by the entity
establishing the IRB, resources necessary
to compensate IRB members, unless they are
already being compensated for their time
and effort on the IRB through other means.
Independence of IRBs
Policies governing the IRB include mechanisms
to ensure independence of the IRB’s operations,
in order to protect decision making from influence
by any individual or entity that sponsors,
conducts, or hosts the research it reviews.
Such policies provide at a minimum that IRB
members (including the Chair) remove themselves
from the review of any research in which they or
close family members have a conflicting interest.
To ensure that the IRB cannot be pressured to
approve or disapprove particular protocols,
the charter, by-laws, policies and/or
procedural rules of the IRB provide that:
1. the IRB’s membership includes at least one
person with no connection to the organization that
sponsors or conducts the research under review;
2. researchers, sponsors, and funders may attend
an IRB meeting to answer questions about their
research protocols and associated documents,
but they are not present when the IRB reaches
decisions about their proposed research;
3. senior decision-makers of
the entity creating the IRB,
or of any organization that sponsors or conducts
the research reviewed by the IRB, such as the
director of an institution, or his or her agent,
do not serve as members of the IRB or its Chair;
4. the entity that establishes
the IRB ensures that IRB members
are protected from retaliation
based on positions taken with
respect to IRB-related matters
or review of research projects.
Training the IRB
Training on the ethical aspects of
health-related research with human participants,
how ethical considerations apply
to different types of research,
and how the IRB conducts its review of research,
is provided to IRB members when they join the
committee and periodically during their committee
service. The training provided to IRB members,
either directly by the appointing entity
or through cooperative arrangements with
other IRBs or organizations that provide
education on research ethics, focuses on:
1. the role and responsibilities of the IRB,
and its role vis-à-vis other relevant entities,
according to relevant international
guidelines (e.g. International Council
on Harmonization Good Clinical Practice or ICH
GCP), national laws, and institutional policies;
2. the full range of ethical considerations
relevant to research with human participants;
3. the application of such ethical
considerations to different types of research;
4. basic aspects of research methodology and
design for members who lack such background;
5. the impact of different scientific designs
and objectives on the ethics of a research study;
6. the various approaches for recognizing and
resolving the tensions that can arise among
different ethical considerations
and modes of ethical reasoning.
When training is supported by research
sponsors, mechanisms are in place to
ensure that the sponsor has no control, direct
or indirect, over the content of the training.
Transparency, accountability,
and quality of the IRB
Mechanisms exist to make
IRB operations transparent,
accountable, consistent, and of high quality.
The entity establishing the IRB employs reliable
means to evaluate whether the staff and members of
the IRB routinely follow the IRB’s policies,
rules, and written procedures, with special
attention to whether the ethical considerations
articulated in international guidelines and
national standards are being considered
and applied consistently and coherently.
Such evaluations are conducted by knowledgeable
and unbiased people at regular, pre-defined
intervals using a pre-defined format. The results
of the evaluation are of a type that can aid the
IRB in reviewing its practice and appraising
performance, rather than apportioning blame,
while also assuring the public that research is
being reviewed according to established standards.
Researchers, research participants,
and other interested parties have
a means of lodging complaints about the
IRB. Such complaints should be reviewed
by an entity other than the IRB itself, and
appropriate follow-up actions should be taken.
Researchers also have a means of
discussing concerns with IRB members,
both on general matters and in response to
IRB decisions on particular research studies.
IRB decisions, excluding confidential information,
are made publicly available, through mechanisms
such as clinical trial registries, web
sites, newsletters, and bulletin boards.
Ethical basis for decision-making in IRBs
The primary task of an IRB is the ethical review
of research protocols and their supporting
documents. Approval or disapproval is based on the
ethical acceptability of the research, including:
• Scientific design and conduct of the study
Research is ethically acceptable only if it
relies on valid scientific methods. IRBs should
have documentation from a prior scientific review,
or should themselves determine that the
research methods are scientifically sound,
and should examine the ethical implications
of the chosen research design or strategy.
Unless already determined by
a prior scientific review,
IRBs should also assess how the study
will be conducted, the qualifications
of the researcher(s), the adequacy of provisions
made for monitoring and auditing, as well as the
adequacy of the study site (e.g. availability of
qualified staff and appropriate infrastructures).
• Risks and potential benefits
In ethically acceptable research,
risks have been minimized, both by preventing
potential harms and minimizing their negative
impacts should they occur, and are reasonable in
relation to the potential benefits of the study.
IRB members should be aware that risks
may occur in different dimensions
(e.g. physical, social,
financial, or psychological),
and harm may occur either at an individual
level or at the family or population level.
• Selection of study population and
recruitment of research participants
Ethically acceptable research ensures
that no group or class of persons
bears more than its fair share of the
burdens of participation in research.
Similarly, no group should be deprived of its fair
share of the benefits of research. These benefits
include the direct benefits of participation
(if any) as well as the new knowledge that the
research is designed to yield. Thus, one question
for research ethics review to consider is whether
the population that will bear the risks of
participating in the research is likely to benefit
from the knowledge derived from the research. In
addition, ethically acceptable research includes
recruitment strategies that are balanced and
objectively describe the purpose of the research,
the risks and potential benefits of participating
in the research, and other relevant details.
• Inducements, financial
benefits, and financial costs
It is considered ethically acceptable
and appropriate to reimburse individuals
for any costs associated with participation in
research, including transportation, child care,
or lost wages. Many IRBs also believe that it is
ethically acceptable to compensate participants
for their time. However, payments should not
be so large, or free medical care or other
forms of compensation so extensive, as to induce
prospective participants to consent to participate
in the research against their better judgement or
to compromise their understanding of the research.
• Protection of research participants’
privacy and confidentiality
Invasions of privacy and breaches of
confidentiality are disrespectful to
participants and can lead to feelings
of loss of control or embarrassment,
as well as tangible harms such as social
stigma, rejection by families or communities,
or lost opportunities such as employment
or housing. IRBs should therefore
examine the precautions taken to safeguard
participants’ privacy and confidentiality.
• Informed consent process
The ethical foundation of informed
consent is the principle of respect for persons.
Competent individuals are entitled to choose
freely whether to participate in research, and to
make decisions based on an adequate understanding
of what the research entails. Decisions for
children or adults who lack the mental capacity
to provide informed consent should be made
by an authorized surrogate decision-maker.
IRBs should examine the process through which
informed consent will occur, as well as the
information that will be provided. IRBs may
waive the requirement of informed consent only
when doing so is consistent with international
guidelines and national standards. While informed
consent to research is important, the fact that
a participant or surrogate may be willing to
consent to research does not, in itself, mean
that the research is ethically acceptable.
• Community considerations
Research has impacts not only on the individuals
who participate, but also on the communities where
the research occurs and/or to whom findings can be
linked. Duties to respect and protect communities
require examining by the IRB and, as far as
possible, are aimed at minimizing any negative
effects on communities such as stigma or draining
of local capacity, and promoting, as relevant,
positive effects on communities, including those
related to health effects or capacity development.
Researchers should actively engage with
communities in decision-making about the
design and conduct of research, including
the informed consent process, while being
sensitive to and respecting the communities’
cultural, traditional and religious practices.
Decision-making procedures for IRBs
Decisions on research protocols
designated for review by the convened IRB
are based on a thorough and inclusive
process of discussion and deliberation.
Protocols involving no more than minimal
risk and burden to research participants
may be reviewed on an expedited basis by one or
more members, rather than the full committee,
if the IRB has established written
procedures permitting such a procedure.
During meetings of the IRB, members engage
in discussions to elicit all concerns and
opinions related to the protocols and the
associated documents under consideration.
The IRB’s rules ensure that the discussions
are respectful of all opinions and allow for
varied beliefs to be aired. Decisions
are made only by those who were present
during the entire discussion. The Chair is
responsible for the decision-making process.
Researchers, funders, or others directly
associated with the protocol in question
are not present during committee
deliberations. IRB members recognize
the limitations of their knowledge and
can seek external input when necessary.
Decisions are arrived at through
either a vote or consensus.
Consensus does not require that all IRB members
support the decision, but that all members
consider the decision at least acceptable and
no member considers the decision unacceptable.